Jesse Pinkman was arguably the most
normal person involved in drug business
in the Breaking Bad franchise from his
empathy for box to his guilt for Gil
Jesse had the strongest emotions by far
but aside from his character he didn't
have much going for him as he barely got
through high school and was cooking meth
to carry day to day life despite is
Walter White who saw potential in Jesse
would take a min as a partner and scale
em up from a garage to super labs run by
kingpins like Gus as well as the cartel
so through the sketchy journey how much
money did jesse pinkman make or actually
how much at Walter White make for Jesse
[Music]
well starting off with their first batch
we know from Jessie giving Walter his
share of $4,000 in Walter's backyard
that Jessie also made $4,000 from the
first batch by their second batch
they already transitioned into doing
business with Tuco though Tuco would
steal this batch from Jesse and beat him
up afterwards Walter would go in soon
after with some former native mercury
and demand that he gets 50k 35k for the
product and 15k for Jesse's pain and
suffering furthermore instead of
splitting this amount in half with each
of them in getting 25k Walter would
actually give Jesse the 17 that half
thousand from the batch plus at all
extra fifteen thousand giving Jesse a
total of 32 thousand five hundred
dollars before Walter left to go some
place of business with the 50k he tells
Tuco that he can get him another two
pounds of following week but this
doesn't actually materialize and they
only end up making zero point five three
pounds
despite this Walter is able to negotiate
with Tuco and get him to give them the
total 70 K as a capital investment
returns for two pounds next week but
after his chilling metal mine from the
nearby chemical factory Walter and Jesse
are actually able to make 4.6 pounds or
2.6 pounds more than what they owe to Co
leading to another ninety one thousand
dollars in revenue but that would be the
last time they make a deal with Tuco so
from the first stage of their little
business Jesse would pawn 117 thousand
dollars of course basically all of that
was spent or lost but that is Jesse
stole income so far after this fiasco
with Tuco since Jesse lost all his money
he would demand that Walter again half
of his share as their 5050 partners
though Walter resists at first and does
keep the majority Walter does end up
giving him four wads of cash assuming
that each of them is $10,000 wads
this gives Jesse another 40 grand ask
for Jesse and Walters first hole
adventure Jesse gets his friends to move
the product and they pay him two grand
per ounce in the first round of doing
this jesse is able to pull in 15 grand
for each of them it should have actually
been 16 but as skinny Pete was robbed
he'd only get 15 to teach the robbers a
lesson Walter would tell Jesse to track
down two robberies and get them
back the situation would play out
nothing like Jessie expected but in the
end from the $4,660.00 he gives Walter
we know that Jesse was able to get that
much as well
after this ATM instant Walter does a
deal with Jesse's friends and assuming
that this is the same one pound as
before this would bring in another 16
grand for each of them later on Walter
and Jesse would cook for four days in
the RV when they would get stuck during
this time they would get 19 bags apart
at a meeting weight of 2.2 pounds
meaning that they had a total of 41
point 8 pounds of product unfortunately
for them right when they start selling
this product combo would be killed
putting their operation at a standstill
until they meet Gus fring now we know
that they sold 38 pounds to Gus for 1.2
million which means that they sold slash
lost about 3.8 pounds before this deal
assuming that point eight pounds was
lost with combo Walter and Jesse would
have pulled in one hundred thirty two
thousand dollars before the deal with
the Gus allowing for sixty six thousand
dollars each and asked for the deal with
the Gus this brings in 1.2 million but
as Saul gets two hundred forty thousand
this leaves 480 thousand each for Jesse
in Walter this adds up to six hundred
and twenty one thousand six hundred and
sixty dollars for Jesse in the second
stage of their business
as for the third stage of their business
this is when they start working for Gus
however before this happens Jesse
decides to cook up one batch without
Walter and Gus actually buys his batch
to try to get Walter to reenter the
business we don't know how much Jesse
cooked or how much Gus paid him but from
the cash that Victor chosen to Walters
car we can see that it is at least seven
wads of 5,000 or at least $35,000
this means that Jesse would have gone
28,800 from this transaction after
accounting for Sol's fees but as Jesse
was the one who cooked it Walter would
also give Jesse his $35,000 share and it
doesn't seem like Saul gets a cut out of
this portion so before Gus in season 3
jesse is able to pull in sixty three
thousand eight hundred dollars after
this Jesse tries to continue on a soul
adventure after Walt abandons him
but he has trouble convincing his
friends to start selling again
in the meantime Hank finds out about the
RV they've been cooking in which leads
to a huge situation but in the end Jesse
Joyce Walter in the super lab with
compensation of 1.5 million dollars over
three months but lucky for Jessie this
only works out for about one batch
prefer Walter is able to negotiate up to
fifteen million dollars a year or about
six hundred and twenty-five thousand
dollars per month for each of them given
that this arrangement lasts for about
four months
this gives Jessie two point five million
dollars sauce cut from Jessie is still
seventeen percent so Jessie would end up
getting about two point four seven five
million from this lucrative job but
since it does start out lower
we'll just call it two million aside
from this Jessie also tries to steal
some pride from Gus and sell it on his
own but this doesn't work out too well
and can be considered a negligible
amount as a result in season 3 and
season four
Jessie is able to pull in a total of two
point oh six three million dollars and
finally that leaves us with the money
from the Jessie Mike and Walter
partnership funny enough though this was
the most complex cook this was the
easiest to calculate they cook one batch
before Jessie and Mike sell the
methylamine leaving Jessie with one
hundred thirty seven thousand dollars
and of course he tells the methylamine
for five million meaning five point one
thirty seven million dollars in season
five adding these all together we get a
total of seven point nine three nine
million or write about seven point five
to eight million dollars of course Jesse
ends up throwing away all of this money
spending it or losing it having less
than 100 K by the end of El Camino
ironically though Jessie was the one
that could have gotten away with all of
it by using the vacuum guy before
everything went berserk but of course as
we discussed in the beginning Jessie's
conscience simply wouldn't allow for
that and hey that's probably for the
best
do you guys think Jessie should have run
away with the money make sure to comment
that down below also if you guys
appreciate the depth of this analysis
make sure drop a like and consider
subscribing to see more question is
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next